امريكا الدوله الاقوى اقتصاديا في العالم
هي صاحبه الدين الاكبر البالغ نحو
31.4 تريليون دولار ليس هذا فقط بل هناك
شكوك حول عجزها عن سداد هذا الدين في
الاول من يونيو المقبل مع استمرار عدم
توصل الكونجرس لاتفاق حول رفع سقف الدين
وبالتالي هذا امر قد يعود بالكوارث على
الولايات المتحده والاقتصاد العالمي برمته
لكن ما هو سقف الدين هو المبلغ الاجمالي
للاموال التي يحق للحكومه الامريكيه
اقتراضها للوفاء بالتزاماتها الحاليه مثل
مدفوعات الضمان الاجتماعي واسترداد
الضرائب وغيرها وعندما يحدث فرق بين الدين
الحكومي والانفاق السنوي يحدث عجز في
الميزانيه وهنا ياتي سؤال اهم ماذا لو
تخلفت الولايات المتحده فعلا عن سداد
ديونها يرى الخبراء ان اخطر العواقب هو
انهيار قيمه الدولار المحيمن على حركه
التجاره العالميه فبالنسبه للشركات
الامريكيه فان هيمنه الدولار تعني انها لا
تخضع لمخاطر سعر الصرف مثل منافسيها
الاجانب اما عالميا فقد تجبر بعض الحكومات
والشركات على دفع فواترها الدوليه بعمله
اخرى ما قد يشكل خطرا على استقرار الاسواق
الماليه العالميه